as far as taste goes so I've heard the
notion of the ick which apparently
translates uh you know for some of the
guys that are more season around my age
translates to things that turn women off
so I'm curious about the ladies you know
in the show is what sort of things with
guys that you've dealt with have given
you the ick in the past vaping vaping
like a okay what
else um drugs that's a big one um also
being significantly different than your
dating profile catfishing you okay with
yeah with photos that are like from five
six years
ago which unfortunately you see that
especially with guys that are in their
late 20s to in their 30s very common
right
now okay what about you laori my ick um
I I prefer a man that doesn't smoke
drink do drugs
um I do not date uh overweight
definitely not overweight what's
overweight like if the guys so you said
six foot tall would be the height so
what would be overweight with six foot
tall well I basically a gut I wouldn't
date a man that has a belly okay got it
yeah all right so just um belly drugs
and
smoking yes and drinking
right what about you
Anna um when he's rude uh can't behave
and
when the kind of nice guy who is doing
everything for a woman like everything
from the beginning like yes yeah
100% so guys have been told Forever by
culture Society Hollywood Music you know
everything just be a nice guy and we've
got two of you right now saying that you
don't like nice guys being nice and kind
like if I can no if I can control them
at if I I can do whatever I want with
him so
it's there's nothing I'm attracting to
anymore so if you can manipulate a guy
then you're not into him right yeah okay
what sort of test do you do you use to
try to see if the guy is persuadable and
manipulable
I actually never done that well I mean
well I mean you did mention that if you
can you know if you can persuade him if
you can manipulate him then you're not
going to be attracted to him so what
sorts of things have you seen guys um
you know Bend
to they seem to show you that right off
the
bat what can you give me an example when
he's always available always have time
want to get me everything want to do
everything with me yeah like
texting yeah yeah yeah yeah they they
seem to show it right away and it's a
turn off immediately yeah yeah like he's
he don't have any any other options so I
am has like so this stuff is so
interesting man because like you see
this stuff it's always for single women
you see this stuff posted on Instagram
all the time and it's always you know I
want to be I want to know where I stand
with you I want to be certain you know
if you're busy just tell me you're busy
and I'll leave you alone if you don't
want to talk just tell me you don't want
to talk and again it's
just the things that women are saying
that they want and we have two that have
said and three they're like no I don't
want that I don't want you to always be
telling me where you are what you're
doing who you're doing I want you to be
going and doing things and I mean when
you say even like I don't you don't even
want to beat your guy's first priority
like can we even go that far no priority
it um um I have I have to have the
feeling he has he has his own business
his own life like let me ask you ladies
this question I'm going to make a
statement and you tell me if you agree
or if you disagree with it a woman wants
a man with a sparkle in his eye but she
doesn't want to be that
sparkle no it have to think about that
yeah I did uh well
it's there's so many ways you can
interpret that though so so to M's Point
earlier you know he was talking about
what's you know what's showing up on
social media you know the women saying
that why doesn't he just let me know
where I stand and why doesn't he respond
and I think the difference between the
annoying nice guy that's always
available and the guy that's not
responding is that she's attracted to
the guy that's not responding and she
wants the guy that's not responding to
be more responsive like the nice guy but
but if you're too responsive and you're
too much of a nice guy then you're going
to turn her off yeah I think when a guy
is too responsive and reaches out to you
too much you kind of get bored right so
I think it needs to go through um the
stages where you're unsure you're unsure
you're unsure you don't really know and
then something usually kind of explodes
or happens and then it all comes out
like well I've checked your Facebook
every day for the last month just to see
if you changed your single status you
know and then it gets changed you know
so it almost seems like you need to go
through the paces in order to have that
Mutual level of respect you can't just
be all in either of you I really hope
you guys enjoyed that clip if you want
to watch the full length podcast you can
find that over here that clip's from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out